كما يقال دائما هناك
الكثير ممن يكتبون الشعر ولكن الشعر قليل
هذه السمه غالبه منذ
بدايه التاريخ نعم انت حتى الان 15 ديوان
اذا بدنا نسال عن يعني هو سؤال شوي تقليدي
عن روافد القصيده عند محمد الاشعري
روافدها كيف تشكلت علاقتها بالمكان
علاقتها باللغه علاقتها بالوجدان علاقتها
بالتامل
بالحنين يعني هناك الكثير من الروافد هي
التي
لها علاقه بكل ذلك نعم
اظن انه هناك رافد اساسي
قليلا ما نتحدث عنه هو رافض القراءه يعني
لا يمكن
للشاعر ان يطور ادواته
التعبيريه والشعريه بدون ان يكون قارئا
جيدا للشعر وللتجارب الاساسيه في الشعر
العالمي هذا يعني انا متيقن انه عنصر
اساسي في بناء الهويه الشعريه لكل شاعر
وبعد ذلك بالطبع هناك اختيارات نمر منها
انا في بدايه تجربتي كنت
كباقي شعراء جيلي
منتبها للقضايا الكبرى التي تؤرق بال
الشعب المغربي انذاك وهي قضايا المتعلقه
بالحريه ومقاومه الاستبداد بالسعي الى الى
الحصول على حقوق ديمقراطيه في البلد وهذا
بالطبع كان
حاسوبيه الشعر في القصيده هذا وكان يوحي
اليه بان الشعر ممكن ان يحقق المعجزات في
هذا الاطار
لكن كما تعرف يعني في في كل تجارب الشعريه
تحدث التحولات والتحول الاساسي الذي حصل
في المغرب هو ان عددا كبيرا من شعراء
السبعينات الذي كانت لهجتهم
السياسيه اقوى من لهجتهم الشعريه في
قصادهم الاولى
توجهوا بعد ذلك بفعل الروافض المتعدده
التي ذكرت بفعل قراءتهم للتجارب الشعريه
العالميه وبفضل ايضا انتباههم لبعض
الاشياء الاساسيه في الحياه وليس فقط في
الشعر ان الطفوله الامكنه
العلاقات الانسانيه
الخيبات الخسارات
الفجائع التي نمر منها
الافراح
التفاصيل اليوميه التي نعيشها
والتي نعتقد ربما خطا انها ليست سوى
تفاصيل ولكن عندما تاخذ الحياه في مجملها
فانها مشكله من هذه التفاصيل